welcome to this video bully Kozma would
nemesis I'm going to do something more
aggressive let's let's just play it
Dutch Dutch defense he knows his opening
so I'm not going to not going to to win
in a blazing faster attack because he's
playing some nonsense he knows his stuff
okay let's see this is a good line how
does like play that maybe c 6 mm yeah
can I go for fork wicking so the tickets
probably probably not i'm not
objectively great okay it's playing a
cookie five okay yeah there are ideas
like that night a 65 I had I had studied
the this line the Leningrad Dutch years
ago when I was looking for an
alternative firm against deform against
us much sharper and 22 to get somewhat
sharper play and I played it a couple of
times with the success actually but yeah
I sort of switch to something else okay
I will I would just push the stuff here
I don't care what he's doing I have such
a bad score against the sky is he going
to play a form maybe I don't know if
taking is good Queen h5 you maybe place
Queenie to order still queen age five
looks like in normals I'm abandoning c6
why am i doing that
they could have he could have taken on
c6 I think I forgot about this idea okay
um do I need to exchange our queen queen
back up really really great if I take it
okay if I retreat he will take on c6 em
he had he had missed this before but he
won't visit at times pretty sure about
that yeah well that's not a bad position
for black I don't don't think so check
okay he's 6 just weakens the d6 porn
there should be six I can I can play or
just the king yeah probably just
thinking
so this this shouldn't be bad for black
really managed to get b5 and I should be
okay
I can I can do that I mean that's why
not unless I'm blundering material
that's the good news I guess activist
219 always need to watch out for the
clock to go here and then I'd fight for
the sea foursquare tick nah he's gotta
mmm ok I see his five is hanging takes
rook takes d5 hangs which is a bit of
shame 94 would have been nice
okay if I retreat the bishop let's just
do that what does he doing with the
special p on on g8 maybe wish Mary bit
of jet at the special age 5 volts on cam
complicated position
Jim I need to be a be quick about all
this it's got many pieces on the default
to to obstruct the pressure on the
channel check
jive this 26 weakness but I don't know
how substantial this is check this look
before and night you form as a defense
can after the rogue traders really not
much going on time morning not sure look
look before does not look great you
might be able to approach the before
porn okay might go go to g1
maybe check
check yeah this is probably am probably
a draw but he's got one minute more on
the clock check this will be the issue
check check check check check he's
playing rook against Luke on time check
it's not like he's accepting a jam check
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check Jane after all it's a
repetition and this saved me yeah it's
just the usual thing what he's doing it
so it's just the typical idiocy of non
increment blitz 62 move 62 we had this
position so 112 is what I would need to
rejet maybe maybe would have made that
106 i managed to 106 Jim Yong yeah he
could have just taken on c6 I guess in
the middle game when i played this
pseudo active month queen age five I'm
sure he can just take him but of course
his game plan is just exchanging
everything off and play play this dead
end games on time it's just like that I
mean it's playing good moves while doing
that usually but it's just automatic for
him to not consider to take just get
everything off okay I must exchange now
and I don't think that this is
particularly dangerous 94 is an
interesting move that the computers are
suggesting quite quite interesting
yeah I have had a quite active position
here good Bishop and active pieces yeah
I think it was just about about equal
for quite a long time I'm not sure here
it's called complicated stuff I guess
Bishop c6 what I want to play this is a
bit pointless I wanted to fight for the
e4 square but are here you can actually
win the game takes TechSoup t6 check at
least win material the problem is that
check check that's even this move coming
and if I try to protect it it's it's in
vain will be lost anyway and i'm already
one paw down ok didn't do that and yeah
i'm not sure i think i defended this I
defended it reasonably well check why
does this a bit better with this great
bishop on d5 she i'm not sure that i
shouldn't i should lose that ok yeah
here's an interesting position I didn't
want to allow the trade but here look
before its bits it's a question but i
think it's it's it's brit song because i
have 93 actually Wow then this would
have been interesting ok computer wants
to go here anyway ok what i was thinking
that this is a problem because he will
approach my porn ok so we got to this
and now the route Kent game king of
three is just much
to point it out by the engine yeah the
bishop is a good piece okay he thought
probably the chance chances in the end
game but I mean chances on position but
after a four it just gets everything it
gets off him takes Jack if this chick
eating here and I'm far too active here
to reduce the game just the draw check
the way it was played this awesome check
check check it was just her just the
same but there was I was reasonably a
quick to secure the draw here alright
thanks for watching